- It's an epidemic that's coming to us.
It's this wave, a pulse of of the virus as
it's spreading from person to person
and growing exponentially.
And the reason that this
is very important is that,
let's say for the sake of argument
100,000 Americans are going
to die of this condition
in the next year.
It makes all the difference in the world,
whether those hundred thousand die over
the course of the next year,
or whether all 100,000
die in the next month.
If they die in the next month,
they're gonna overwhelm
our healthcare system.
And many more Americans will
die, that would have died
if we allowed our healthcare system
and our supply chain to work.
(upbeat music)
- Joining me today is a
sociologist and physician
known for his research on social networks
and the socio-economic,
bio-social and evolutionary
determinants of behavior,
health and longevity.
Nick Christakis, welcome
back to The Rubin Report.
- Thank you for having me, Dave.
- I'm glad to have you back,
wish we could be doing this live.
But obviously, we're practicing a little
social distancing right now.
With everything going on with corona,
I've been trying to find a wide
array of people to talk to.
You put out, what I thought was a really
fantastic Twitter thread.
I rarely send people to Twitter,
but you put out a great Twitter thread
that covered this through
all of the disciplines
that I just read there in your bio,
which are quite extensive.
So let's just start one at a time,
the two things that
people have heard the most
about at the moment, social distancing,
and flattening the curve.
Can you just explain both
and why they're important right now?
- Yeah, so the virus takes
advantage of the fact that
we are social animals.
That we assemble in groups,
that we have friends,
that we touch each other
and hug each other.
And it uses those connections
that we assemble ourselves
into these networks.
It uses those connections as a highway
to travel through our species.
And so the challenge for us right now
is how to interrupt that highway,
how to break the paths that the virus uses
to travel from person to
person, to person to person.
The reason that's important
is that this flattening
the curve idea, so we're gonna
engage in social distancing,
we're gonna stop
interacting with each other,
we're gonna keep physically
apart from each other.
That's the most important thing.
In fact, I've been advocating
for a shift in terminology,
to physical distancing
from social distancing.
In other words, we can
still interact socially,
but from a distance, like
you and I are doing now.
And so we want physical distancing.
It's irony we wanna like,
bond together, at the same
time as we are sort of
separating from each
other in terms physically.
Anyway, the reason we're engaging in that
physical distancing is to cut
the path through the network.
And the reason we're doing
that, is to flatten the curve.
What does that mean?
Well, it's an epidemic
that's coming to us,
it's this wave, a pulse of
the virus as it's spreading
from person to person and
growing exponentially.
And the reason that this
is very important is that,
let's say, for the sake of argument,
100,000 Americans are going
to die of this condition
in the next year, it makes all
the difference in the world,
whether those 100,000 die over
the course of the next year,
or whether all 100,000
die in the next month.
If they die in the next month,
they're gonna overwhelm
our healthcare system,
and many more Americans will
die than would have died
if we allowed our healthcare system
and our supply chain to work.
So we wanna flatten the curve.
We have got this peak
of a curve, the epidemic
is coming at us
and it's gonna hit lots of
people at the same time.
We wanna stop it from doing
that, and flatten the curve
and push it out into the future.
And when we do that, we
achieve a number of objectives.
First of all, at any given point,
fewer people are sick
so our healthcare system
can take care of them.
Many more might live as a result of that.
Second, we push some of the
cases out into the future,
so that maybe some of the
people that gets sick eventually
will get sick at a time when
we've invented a vaccine,
or we know better how to treat the people.
So we also gain that benefit
by flattening the curve.
And as I said, not only do
we decompress our healthcare
system, not only do we push
people into the future,
when we might be better
able to care for them,
but we reduce mortality as well.
So maybe instead of 100,000
dying, maybe 90,000 die
if we push it forward.
So that's why we're social distancing
and that's what flattening
the curve means.
- So I guess the obvious
follow up then is,
do we have any evidence that
the things that we are doing
at the moment or being
told to do is working?
Is the curve being flattened?
- We cannot know yet because,
we have not had adequate
testing in this country.
We don't have adequate surveillance,
like they did in China and Korea.
And so we really can't be sure.
We know this type of behavior,
this social distancing behavior,
the banning of public gatherings,
the closure of schools,
the reduction in group
size, the self-isolation,
we know that that works
from other epidemics,
but we cannot yet know
how much it's working in
the United States right now
because we don't have
the kind of surveillance
we need to see it.
- So I think when people
hear about social distancing,
and as you called it physical distancing,
I think people are confused or worried.
What about the people that are actually
in the house with them
family, kids, parents,
whatever it is, that might have to go out
and then come back into the house?
- Yeah, that's a risk that we
run and that the Chinese ran,
when they locked down 930
million people in their countries
since January the 25th.
So typically, what you do is you try
to compress all of your shopping,
in fact Americans should begin
to be doing that right now.
Instead of going out three
times a week to buy stuff
go out once a week, compress everything,
minimize the amount of
time you're out and about.
When the person does go
out, they should ideally
try to wash their hands frequently,
not press elevator buttons.
The Chinese have all these
ingenious things where,
when you go into an elevator,
there's like a little pin
cushion of toothpicks,
and you take a toothpick,
you press your button,
and then you discard the toothpick.
So that you're not
touching buttons because
the virus can spread on smooth surfaces,
that's called fomites.
So, a person leaving the
household should do that.
If someone in the household does get sick
and they are tested positive,
you can, in principle,
isolate that person for two weeks
from other members of the household,
or in the worst case scenario,
they infect the other
people in the household,
but nevertheless, it's then
constrained to one household.
Keep in mind that, most people infected by
this pathogen do fine.
The great majority of
people will have no symptoms
or will have minor symptoms.
Some people however, maybe
25% over will get sick,
and of those, maybe a fifth of those
so total of 5% maybe
of the people infected,
will get seriously ill.
And then of course, on
average, we don't know exactly
how many of the people
who are infected will die.
And the reason, again we don't know is
we don't have good testing.
So we don't know what the denominator is,
we don't know of 10,000
people who are infected,
we know that because they were tested,
let's say, what happens to them?
And how many of them get sick?
And how many of them need ICU care?
And how many of them die?
We don't know that denominator accurately.
But our best estimate is
that, of those infected
somewhere between half a percent
and one and a half percent will die.
And that's a large number,
but it's very graded by age.
So if you're younger than 25,
your risk of death is very
small, maybe 0.2% that's a
big risk for young person,
but nevertheless, it's a small risk.
And then middle-aged
people around 50 or 60,
it's about 1%, and then
above 80, it's about 20%.
So it's a very steep curve with age.
- Do you have a recommendation then
if you're in the household right now,
and you're any of these
ages, let's say you're 25,
you're 50, and you're 80,
let's just go with those ages.
And you're not feeling great,
should you be then trying
to go to the hospital
or I guess maybe if you're
80 you are, or just stay home
and deal with it the best you can.
- Yeah, in general, one
of the things we all need
to be very good about doing right now is,
giving our healthcare workers a break.
So you should not be going to the hospital
with a sniffles right now.
There are a few things
that Americans should do,
you should get a flu shot.
One of the reasons you
should get a flu shot
is not because the flu shot prevents you
from getting coronavirus, it does not.
But if you get a flu shot,
it lowers your risk of
actually getting the flu
and therefore, you won't go
to the hospital with the flu.
And now is not a good time for you,
to be burdening our healthcare
system for your own sake,
or for the sake of the system.
Furthermore, going to the hospital
if you're not actually sick,
or if you're just mildly sick,
there are a lot of actually
seriously sick people there,
you might get the germ from them.
In a hospital waiting room
is not a time to be right now
unless you actually need it.
So generally speaking, the
symptoms of coronavirus
are variable, you should
have a fever above 101.5,
it's in about 85% of people,
not everyone but most people have a fever.
A dry cough would be a symptom
and then there's a shortness of breath.
Certainly, if you have
shortness of breath and a fever,
absolutely, you should go to the hospital.
And then there's a whole
host of other symptoms
at lower percentages.
So if you're a 25-year-old
person and you have a runny nose,
and low great temperature
and some muscle aches,
it's probably not coronavirus,
stay home until you get sicker.
That would be a reasonable choice.
If you're an older person,
then you should have a lower threshold.
And ideally, if you
went, we would test you,
but we can't, we don't
have enough testing yet.
We're hopefully the country
will get better at that
in the coming months.
- Yeah, all right, I wanna
keep going through this
Twitter thread 'cause
you hit it just sort of
at every possible level.
So you talked about
reasons to close schools,
even if kids there aren't sick.
- Yeah, I mean, school closures,
there's a lot of debate about this.
There are two kinds of school closures,
and most of the country's
shutting the schools anyway now.
So this point is, is behind us.
I was sending out this
information like three
or four weeks ago, but school
closures are two kinds.
There's reactive school closure,
when there's a case in the
school, and you close the school
and that's pretty uncontroversial.
I mean, most parents, teachers,
public health experts,
there's an outbreak of
epidemic in the school.
Let's close the school.
And it's been shown that if you do that,
if you close the schools in an area,
you lower the cumulative
prevalence of the condition
by about 25% and postpone the
epidemic by a week or two,
which is good.
So, reactive school closures
helpful but, it's not as good
as we can do that even better,
is something called
proactive school closure.
When you close the schools,
even before there's a case in the schools.
For instance, you living
in a mid-size town,
there's a case in the
community, it's something called
the community-acquired case.
So it's not like someone
from Italy or China
flew to your town, landed, had symptoms
and you diagnose them.
That would be an imported
case, maybe you could isolate
that person and self
quarantine the people who
they connected with.
No, we're talking about
a situation in which
someone in the community is diagnosed,
and we have no idea where they got it.
They're like a canary in the coal mine,
and if that's happening, you
can be quite confident that
within a week or two,
it's gonna be in school.
So why not close the school
now, reduce the force of
the epidemic by decreasing social mixing.
And ironically, even though
the kids aren't affected by
this condition, they still
can transmit the pathogen
even though they themselves sick.
And furthermore, one of the
ways that school closure works
is precisely because, it compels
the parents to stay home.
So it reduces the parents
interacting with each other.
That's how it works in part.
- Yeah, it sounds like
we've basically done this
pretty well, maybe a little
later than you wanted to
but it sounds like now we're there, right?
- Definitely, later than we wanted to.
And for schools that are still open,
what I would strongly recommend,
and my wife and I had an article
in The Atlantic about this
a few days ago, is if you
insist on staying open,
and I don't think that's
the best course of action,
at least, you can implement
a whole host of other
harm mitigation strategies.
For example, give parents the choice,
if they wanna keep their kids
home, they should stay home.
I wanna mention this
because it's also relevant
to employers and workers.
Allowing any worker who can
work at home, to work at home
it's not just good for that worker
from like their selfish point of view.
It helps everybody, because
you reduce the number of people
at the office.
So only the people that have to be there,
should be there, same with schools.
If some parents wanna keep the school
should let them keep their kids home,
you can broaden drop
off and pick up hours.
So not everyone is arriving
between eight and 8:15
to drop off their kids,
bumping against each other,
as they come through the door,
parents interacting you let's say,
you give a 45 minute drop off.
It needs a bit more manpower
on the part of the school,
but you reduce the social
density at pickup and drop off.
Cancel staff meetings,
provide cafeteria seating,
broaden the lunch hour,
and have the kids sit every other chair.
These are things that schools
can do if they insist on
staying open maybe in our Southern States,
for instance, where maybe the
virus hasn't hit so much yet,
but that nevertheless are helpful.
- So you sort of hit this one already.
But do you wanna add
anything generally on how
the flu spreads within social networks?
- Well, first of all, we call this the flu
and there's a broad category
of respiratory diseases,
influenza the flu is a
particular kind of virus.
This is a corona virus,
which is a little different,
but I call it the flu too maybe, I'm lazy.
But this is a kind of
flu, the corona virus,
there are other corona virus,
like the common cold is caused
by about 200 different viruses.
About five of them are corona
viruses, just like COVID-19
or SARS-CoV-2, which is affecting us now.
And we've gotten used to it,
just to just to cut ahead
to the chase.
The ultimate outcome of
this situation is that
a new virus has been
introduced into our species,
it's gonna become what's called endemic.
Just gonna be there all the
time, like the common cold,
like the flu, we hope it'll
reduce in its severity,
we hope we humans will eventually slowly
become immune to it and we
will get sort of hard immunity.
So some people will continue
to get this forever now,
but hopefully at less intensity,
and not all at once, so
that our healthcare system
can care for them.
Anyway, so the corona virus,
and the flu, and influenza
and other pathogens, rhinovirus
that causes the common cold.
These cause respiratory disorders,
and the corona virus is one of them.
I actually forgot your
question, I'm sorry.
- The question was how it
spreads within social networks,
which you've sort of been
hitting throughout this?
- Yeah, so it spreads
exactly across social ties.
And in the Twitter thread
you're alluding to,
I have an animation that
shows if you map a network,
you can see it like, light up.
And one of the things that's
been so difficult for people
to understand, and it's
a little bit related
to this network idea.
Is that epidemics start
slowly, for the longest time,
it seems like nothing is happening.
But it's in the nature
of exponential growth,
that nothing is happening,
nothing is happening,
nothing is happening and
then all of a sudden,
a lot happens.
And this has been why
it's been so difficult
for many Americans to appreciate.
They look around and they're
like, nothing's happening.
But if we monitor the
situation, we see the case are
doubling, the virus is on the loose.
We go from 10, a week later
to 20, a week later to 40.
And we think they're just 40 cases
in the United States, who cares?
Then it's 80, then it's 160
cases, but then before you know
we have 10,000, 20,000,
40,000, 100,000, 200,000,
and it's just on the loose.
And that's why everyone
is so alarmed right now,
all the public health professionals.
- So that's actually the perfect segue
to what your next tweet in
the thread was which is,
how these epidemics come in waves.
And then interestingly,
how this is actually related to weather.
- Yes, so one of the things
to understand about this is that
probably judging from previous pandemics,
maybe 40% of Americans
will be infected with this,
maybe less, maybe 10 or
20%, maybe up to 60%.
With the 1957 pandemic,
ultimately about 40% of Americans
were infected, but it comes in waves.
So you were hit by the first pulse of it,
typically in the summer, for
a combination of reasons,
including that human beings go outside,
we're not as densely packed,
maybe the ventilation outside
reduces the transmission of the pathogen,
maybe the heat or the humidity play a role
in reducing the transmissibility
of the pathogen.
So our behavior changes,
the biology of the pathogen
is such, that the temperature
and humidity affected,
transmission tends to decline.
But then, the virus has gone
to the Southern Hemisphere,
where it's winter there,
during our summer.
And then, when we returned to
work in school in September,
it comes back, this is
a very typical scenario.
So unfortunately, it's likely not certain
and I need to again emphasize
that, everything I'm telling
you today, is based on the
best available knowledge
to the best of my knowledge.
It's possible that a year from now,
people will watch this video
and think I was right about
this and wrong about that,
and that's just the knowledge
we have now.
This pathogens only been
with us for three months.
It started, we think in
mid-December in Wuhan,
and it started spreading around
the world in mid-January.
It was already in Seattle by mid-January,
we know from genetic analysis,
and then we're sort of spreading.
And now here we are in
March 18, two months after
mid-January, that's a not a
lot of time for scientists
to figure out what's going on.
So anyway, so we think it'll
spend the summer mostly in
the Southern Hemisphere,
although, we'll have some
cases and then it'll come back
in the fall.
And in the 1918 pandemic,
the second wave was deadlier
than the first wave.
So, in 1957 that wasn't as much the case.
So we don't know exactly
what's gonna happen,
but then they'll probably be
a second, maybe a third wave,
and eventually, basically,
we'll get used to it.
And it'll just sort of
be there all the time.
- So since you mentioned Seattle,
and we're talking about weather.
So Seattle, it sounds like
they've got a strange situation
or a more severe situation
going on there perhaps.
It also rains a lot
there, I'm here in SoCal,
where it's sunny and 70 every day,
although, it has been raining last week.
I mean, could that alone,
just the weather patterns
like that affect any of this?
- Well, the Chinese
scientists have done some
research on this.
We don't know, is the
answer to that question.
People hope, they're hints
in multiple directions.
I do not think we're gonna
have a complete weather cure,
that is to say, I don't think
the disease is simply gonna
disappear, because of the weather.
The evidence is conflicting.
If I had to guess I would say
that probably we'll get some reduction
in cases from the warmth and the humidity.
But it's hard to know what.
The Chinese did some analysis
because their country is so large,
where they looked at transmission
all throughout China,
and in some parts of China it
was hot, in some parts cold,
in some parts humid, in some parts not.
And they kinda looked and saw,
where was transmission the worst.
And it seems like, optimal
transmission is around
40 degrees Fahrenheit on
average daily temperature
so cold, but so when you get
much colder, much hotter,
that seems to be better, less
transmission but not zero.
And then they looked at humidity,
and it looks like very dry weather is bad.
So if humidity is less than 5%,
that's not particularly good.
But if you look at
weather patterns for where
the virus has struck, so
far, it seems that countries
closer to the equator
seem to be doing better.
So it's a mixed picture.
I don't know the answer,
but if I had to guess,
I think the weather will
make some difference,
but I don't think it'll
be definitive difference.
- So I think I'm actually
gonna skip the next one
in the thread because you were talking
about vulnerable groups.
But since you're talking about...
'Cause I think we've
sort of hit that already
unless there's anything
else you wanna add about
older people or sick people.
- Yeah, I think we have to be mindful.
People on dialysis, people
with chronic illnesses,
institutionalized people, the
elderly, homeless populations.
And one of the things
that's really important
to understand about it pandemic is that,
it's the great equalizer,
we're all in this together.
Actually, the reason
you should care about,
let's say the homeless, or
people who are chronically ill
is not just because you should be kind,
and compassionate and altruistic.
It's actually your own
selfish interest too,
because we do not want
populations that are reservoirs
of this pathogen.
We wanna take care of everybody,
so we all can be safer.
This is why social distancing.
When you practice social distancing,
you're actually showing
kindness to others.
One of the ironies is that people think,
"Oh, I'm gonna be brave and
show kindness by shaking
"people's hands and being out and about."
Ironically, that's not
the kind thing to do.
The kind thing to do is to
remove yourself from circulation,
so that you're not
circulating the pathogen.
That's the best thing
you can do for your group
or your society.
- I actually didn't mean to
diminish any of those groups,
but because you were
hitting on the China part,
which was the next tweet,
I was gonna jump over that.
So you actually, in the thread
you called it
- I wasn't suggesting
you were.
- No, I know.
- I wasn't suggesting...
I was just saying
I was taking advantage of
the opening to point out
to people in case it wasn't obvious
why it's not just a
question of compassion,
it's actually in our self-interest,
to take care of these populations.
- So you talked a little bit about China.
We live in this time where it's like,
half the people are saying,
"China unleashed this
"on the world," half
the people are saying,
"China has done nothing wrong."
You called in your Twitter thread,
you called China's response astonishing.
Can you explain that?
- Well, first of all, we would
know from genetic analysis
if this was an engineered weapon,
and that's a conspiracy
theory, there's absolutely no
evidence that any such thing happened.
And so, they certainly didn't
release it deliberately
because they're killing their own people
and because of the study,
so that's ridiculous.
No, what I was describing
is China because of its
totalitarian or authoritarian,
rather, government
and its collectivist culture
was able to put 930 million
people under a kind of
home-based quarantine
beginning January the 25th
for like eight weeks.
It never in the history of public health,
has so many people been under
such restriction for so
long to my knowledge.
It's unbelievable what
they were able to do
because of their culture
and their government.
And I call this a social
nuclear weapon because,
it gives you a sense of
what they were fighting,
the power of this pathogen
that they were confronting
that they resorted to this.
China did not decide to do this for fun.
And when I was trying to
communicate with that thread,
that was now weeks ago,
was to try to get attention
in the United States,
like, look what's happening in China.
This is not gonna just stay there,
this is not like a Chinese problem.
They've decided to put a billion
people under home arrest,
for two months for fun.
We need to prepare, we
need to think about this
because, the virus is
gonna reach our shores.
In fact, already when I was writing that,
it had reached our shores.
This is what happens in pandemics.
No matter where the disease starts,
it spreads around the globe,
and by the time you're aware of it,
even if you're aware of it,
30 days after inception,
it's too late given movements of people.
Even frankly, a hundred years ago,
given movements of people on steamboats,
and on trains and big compact
cities, the virus spreads.
So, anyway, I was trying to
describe what the Chinese
had done and it is
astonishing what they did.
And they have brought down
their cases in a country of 1.4
billion people to under...
Now, it's like, I don't even know,
it's like 10 cases a day or something
in the whole nation.
So this is, unfortunately what
we are facing in our country.
And we have different strengths
and different weaknesses
compared to China.
One of their weaknesses,
we have a commitment
to free and open
expression in our society.
And in China, unfortunately,
the doctor who first tried
to sound the alarm, Dr. Wenliang Li,
he was brought in on
charges of rumor mongering.
He was basically using the
Facebook equivalent in China,
and messaging his friends and saying,
"Oh my God, I'm seeing all
these patients in the hospital
"with this particular kind of pneumonia,
"I'm worried we have a new pathogen."
And the local authorities called him in
and accused him of rumor mongering,
which is not a crime in our society.
- Not yet.
- No
So, I mean our strengths in
our society include our wealth,
our openness, our tremendous scientists.
But we haven't been
playing to those strengths,
we've not been listening
to our scientists,
we've not been deploying our wealth,
we haven't been acting the
way we should be acting,
and taking our strengths
to cope with this.
And the Chinese use
different strengths and they
frankly, coped very effectively with this.
I should say, just to be clear,
what the Chinese
accomplished was they stopped
the spread of the pathogen,
but they did not eradicate it.
So the pathogen is still there,
and it will come back even
to China, as it will come back to us.
But they have bought themselves
a huge amount of time
to organize their response now,
so they don't lose countless lives.
- Okay, so actually, I think
most of the other things in
the thread you've already hit,
so I'll only ask you one more
and then I just wanna do two
or three audience questions real quick.
You mentioned the 1957
flu pandemic before.
Can you talk about some of the
similarities and differences
to what we're dealing with now?
- Yeah, well 1918, of
course, was the big one.
That was the so called Spanish
Flu, which swept the world,
killed many millions of
people, including our country.
It was a different time.
Of course, people were starving
because of the war, there
was a lot of disruption
because of the war.
And it was a different pathogen,
and there was no modern
medicine, no antibiotics,
even against bacteria, and
we think many of those people
died, not just because
of the viral infection,
but then their lungs got
so called super infected
with bacterial pneumonia,
which killed them, many people.
So a lot was different then,
and we earlier we talked about
how they came in three
waves and it was awful.
And there was a great
depression of course,
afterwards as well.
So, I don't think, around the same time.
Anyway, I don't think that
this pandemic is thankfully
gonna be that bad.
But the nearest analog I can see,
even though it was a different pathogen,
and in some ways had
different epidemiology.
For example, in 1957, the
pathogen also killed young people,
whereas this one does not.
I think '57 might be a good
model for what we're facing.
So every 10 years or so, at risk viably,
but at an unpredictable time,
the world has a pandemic.
Most of your listeners will
remember SARS, or H1N1, or MERS
and those have petered out,
so people they don't take them seriously
and they peter out for
a variety of reasons.
Ironically, one of the reasons is that,
sometimes they're too deadly.
For instance, SARS was
about 10 times as deadly,
as the COVID that we're facing now.
And when a disease is too deadly,
it kills its victim too fast,
so the person can't spread it.
So this particular pathogen we're facing,
has sort of middling level lethality,
it's neither too benign, nor too deadly,
it's not as deadly as the 1918 virus,
and it has middling
level transmissibility.
It's not very difficult to transmit,
and it's not too hard to transmit.
And it's sort of in the
middle there and in my view,
it seems to be behaving
similar to the '57 pandemic,
which should be clear.
Some of your listeners
older ones may remember it,
but many people won't.
And part of the reason
people don't remember this,
we didn't have the same
media environment then
and of course, people
were dealing with polio
and other deadly diseases.
But that pandemic swept
over the United States
and killed we think about a
hundred and 10,000 people,
which back then, was half as
deadly as all of the cancer
in the United States.
So today, if we have a '57 pandemic,
we're talking hundreds of
thousands of Americans dying
from COVID, if the disease
is half as deadly as cancer,
as a group.
So it's serious, it
could be quite serious.
I also wanna just take an
opportunity again to say,
we don't know exactly what's gonna happen
and what's very important
for your listeners is
to understand that despite
political polarization,
and despite our desire
to simplify our choices,
should we have rice krispies,
or should we have cornflakes?
There are shades of gray and
there's nuance when it comes
to serious policy dilemmas,
and serious scientific questions.
So there's a range of
outcomes we could observe
in the United States from this.
We don't know exactly
what's going to happen,
but at best, 35,000
Americans are going to die,
in my view, at best.
And it's quite possible
that 20% of Americans
will get infected.
That's 60 million
Americans in the next year.
And our best estimate
is that half a percent
of those people might die.
That's 300,000 Americans dying
in the next year of this condition.
And that's possible.
We're not sure it's gonna happen.
It might not happen.
I hope it doesn't happen,
but it's possible and that
is a very, very heavy burden.
That's 1957 pandemic.
That's half as deadly as
cancer, approximately.
So that's why everyone is taken seriously.
- So I got a ton of questions
specifically for you
because I posted in the
Rubin Report community,
I posted that we're having you on,
I had everyone look at the thread.
So what I thought I'd do is
I'll just ask you two or three now,
and then I'm just gonna email you
one email with all these questions,
and maybe as you have a
little time here and there,
you can throw some things on Twitter
that are maybe a little more specific.
Obviously, that's totally up to you.
But I'll just ask you two or three now.
I thought this was really interesting,
and I got a lot of this type of question.
What is the acceptable level
of risk in terms of disease
and death that we're willing to accept
in order to have a normally
functioning society
and healthy economy?
- Well, I would ask you
to think about what we do
when it comes to mining safety,
or other dangerous occupations
like whether we equip our police
with bulletproof vests, for example.
We spend money in a preventive
way to prevent deaths
and hazardous occupations all the time.
Now, we don't spend limitlessly,
we don't equip each police officer,
we expect people to
take some risk of death.
We don't spend limitlessly
even to secure our highways.
Not every highway is a divided highway,
which we know is safer,
because it would cost too much.
So there's some calculation we make
about how much money
we're willing to spend
in order to save lives.
And what you have to understand
in this case is that we're
dealing with a threat.
And instantly death is expensive too,
like all these people dying
and consuming healthcare is expensive.
So, preventing those death
saves us money as well.
I acknowledge as most experts do,
that taking our economy
is a devastating thing.
But I would suggest that if
people started dying like flies,
if 300,000 Americans started dying,
our economy would have tanked anyway.
So the problem again, is not that 300,000
extra Americans are gonna
die, although that's not good.
It's that they're gonna
die very compressed.
We're not just spreading them out.
And so that's a devastating
blow to our society
no matter what.
So I guess, I would say that
in answer to your question that
we always are willing to pay
some economic costs to save lives,
and I acknowledge that going
into a major depression,
or a major recession,
and possibly a depression
is a huge cost for our society.
But I would suggest to you
that we would likely
have faced that anyway,
if we had done nothing,
but then we also would have
had all of these deaths,
so I think it's necessary.
- Yeah, all right.
So we're just gonna do two more.
I know you've got a
crazy day ahead of you.
And then I'm just gonna
email you some of these,
and maybe you can get to some of them.
But there were also a bunch about this.
Is there any confirmation whether
airborne transmission is possible?
I mean, if someone has it
and you're at the store,
and you're avoiding
everybody the best you can
and you're wearing gloves
and the rest of it,
but somebody breathes on
you or sneezes on you,
or something like that. I think
there's a little confusion
as to what airborne transmission
actually mean maybe.
- Yeah, so droplet transmission
is when a liquid, like I
sneeze or cough or spit,
and they're droplets
that go through the air
and land on you, in
your nose or your mouth
and transmits it to you,
and that's why we're supposed to stay,
four or five or six feet
away from each other
because if I sneeze and
I'm six feet away from you,
the droplets would go through the air
and then fall into the
ground and not reach you.
Airborne is when tiny particulates,
maybe the virus itself
are floating through the
air, and can reach you.
We believe that there is both droplet
and airborne transmission,
and is probably fecal transmission as well
which is a little bit
concerning of this pathogen
and something called fomite transmission,
which is that the pathogen
can stay on surfaces,
especially smooth surfaces.
So porous things like paper
money or fabrics, less so,
but smooth surfaces like
elevator buttons, doorknobs,
kitchen counters, can stay more.
But the virus is also very fragile.
It's encapsulated in a lipid Kote.
The viruses work by
taking over our own cells,
and they grow inside ourselves,
and then they explode out of ourselves.
And as they explode out,
they take a little bit of
our cell membrane with them,
so they're encapsulated
in this lipid membrane,
and that helps them to
be more transmissible,
but it makes them very vulnerable to soap.
So cleanliness, this is
why washing your hands,
and when you wash your hands,
you should wash between your fingers
and the backs of your hands.
Many people are saying,
"Sing the Happy Birthday song
"twice while you wash your hands."
It's true, but that does kill the virus.
So when you go out and about,
if you avoid touching your face,
if you wash your hands
before you return home,
that is very basic hygiene.
That's actually very helpful.
And experiments have
shown this by the way,
it's not just old wives tales.
Like people actually do
studies where they touch stuff,
and then they wash their hands
and they see if the virus goes away.
- Yeah, all right.
So the last one then is I got
a couple of versions of this
that we're all concerned about this
and even the way I'm
trying to do these shows,
I'm not trying to
overload people too much.
And I don't want everyone
glued to their TVs endlessly.
What else do you make of just sort of
the human condition in the
midst of a pandemic like this?
- Well, as you know,
because we talked about it
the last time you and I
met, I just wrote this book.
- Yeah, you got a whole book about it.
It's right over there.
- I know.
I wrote this book called,
"Blueprint: The Evolutionary
Origins of a Good Society."
And as you know, Dave, I'm an optimist.
I believe in human beings.
I marvel at our capacity for goodness.
I recognize our capacity
for evil and selfishness
and tribalism and violence.
But I also revere and
admire our capacity for love
and friendship, and
cooperation and teaching.
In fact, all of these are things
that we're using right now
to confront this virus.
We are banding together
and working together
to fight off this invader.
We are using our capacity for teaching.
The reason we know what
to do in this case,
is because previous humans
who confronted this virus
wrote down, "Here's what you do
"when you're facing a pandemic."
You literally can go...
There's a book right here, I can look over
and see it's called,
"National Strategy for
Influenza Pandemics."
Like there are books that you
can open up like a cookbook
and they say, "Here's what you
do when there's a pandemic."
It's amazing.
We can transmit this
knowledge to each other
and therefore, cope with this enemy,
the virus that is attacking us.
So this is why I am
hopeful and optimistic.
The virus will eventually
pass, our species will survive.
It is unfortunate that many will die.
We don't know how many.
The virus will become endemic.
We will see the other side of this,
but we do have to work
together as a society
to shore up our industries,
to protect our healthcare workers,
from whom we're gonna
ask tremendous amounts,
and from whom we're gonna
ask to take tremendous risks.
When I was a doctor, I
mean, I'm a physician
and I don't see patients anymore,
but when I was patients,
especially in the 1990s,
the HIV epidemic was very prominent.
And there was a lot of concern
that if you took care
of patients with HIV,
and a lot of those patients were gay,
or they were from Haiti,
or they were drug users,
they were groups that back then
were especially stigmatized.
And so there was a lot of like, kind of,
"Oh, well, we won't take
care of those people."
And there was fear among
healthcare providers,
like if you stuck them, and
you got their blood on you,
you might contract this deadly disease.
But we were expected
to take personal risks.
We were expected to
care for these patients.
It's a calling to be a doctor or a nurse.
It's a moral obligation.
And so we expect a huge amount
from our doctors and nurses
and health care providers right now.
We expect them to take these risks.
But it's not the same to
expect them to take the risks
with the proper equipment
versus to send them to certain death.
That is to say without masks,
gloves, protective equipment.
And so I'm very concerned
that we're not taking this serious,
we don't have the right equipment
to equip our frontline medical
personnel to deal with this.
And this is why I'm also
upset that we squandered
the six weeks that the
Chinese bought for us
by locking down their nation.
We should have been planning
to equip our hospitals
with this personal protective
equipment, with ventilators,
with staffing, with procedures
at which we can discuss,
it's too technical and boring,
to confront this epidemic.
So we're behind now, is the problem,
and I hope very much we can catch up.
And this is again, why social
distancing is so important
to slow this thing down so
we can let our supply chain,
our scientists, our politicians, frankly,
catch up so that we can cope with this.
- Well, Nick, I always consider
you one of the cleanest,
clearest thinkers that we've got,
and especially in a time like this,
so I appreciate you taking the time.
And maybe we'll get you back on
in a couple weeks as
this thing continues to
(overlapping conversation)
- Yes.
Thank you very much for having, David,
and thank you to your listeners.
- Hey everyone, we're obviously
in some unchartered
territory with coronavirus,
and our plan here is to
help you make as much sense
of the situation in a
nonalarmist fashion as possible.
If you're looking for reliable
information from experts
on the frontlines of the pandemic,
check out our coronavirus playlist,
which we'll keep adding
updates to right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe.